okay I've not been talking about this
for a while because I don't want to
overdo it there's so much news to talk
about but being the beginning of a new
month and because this is a growing
problem I've got to talk about it today
and I hope you'll indulge me for just a
few minutes the david pakman show is in
trouble
okay and and we are getting increasingly
crushed by what is now known as ad
pocalypse or the YouTube advertiser
boycott and I'll catch you up real quick
on March 31st after a couple of
corporate media articles were written
including in the wall street journal
journal alleging that YouTube's ad
algorithm was unable to prevent racist
content from showing ads from major
brands like coca-cola YouTube panicked a
bunch of brands panicked threatening to
pull out their money from YouTube
YouTube flip the switch and made it so
that on any Content that is quote
potentially controversial or sensitive
as wouldn't play
unfortunately basically everything we
talked about is considered or was at
that point by YouTube's new algorithm
potentially controversial or sensitive
the algorithm stopped distinguishing
between for example Isis propaganda and
a video we do talking about how to
defeat Isis in the eyes of the YouTube
ad algorithm at that time those videos
were indistinguishable and we lost 99%
of our ad revenue without giving you the
minutiae of the highs and lows of how
this has gone since March 31st I will
tell you that for one period we
recovered about 15% of our ad revenue
then we got back about a third of it we
had a major crash at the end of June the
last week of June was was a disaster and
the first three days of July for which
we have data so far have been a total
and utter disaster we're back down to
about 12 to 15 percent of the YouTube ad
revenue that we once had there's really
no other way for me to say this other
than we've got to make up that revenue
and this is something that at this point
appears to be the new normal
I've been working with my contacts at
YouTube and they have been responsive
polite nice and seemingly eager to help
but this appears to be above their pay
grade
that's just the bottom line and we are
now in a situation where it's been all
of April all of May in all of June and
other than about a third recovery that
took place during the majority of the
month of May
we're in rough shape right now okay so
we are trying to make up that ad revenue
because you know what this is sort of a
key time for independent progressive
media you see more hostility than we've
seen for decades towards media towards
adversarial media from the current White
House and administration we have I think
at this point Pat this is incredible
we've got close to 10 or 12 long-form
investigative pieces on our schedule
that we are going to start chipping it
away at and working on and those are
much more involved pieces than the
day-to-day stories that we do on the
show and I want to bring those to you
I'm committed to bringing those to you
and and in order to continue funding the
entire operation we've just got to make
up this revenue okay so there's a few
ways that you can help and and I want to
be super clear we're not talking about
any one individual making a major
contribution okay here's some of the
ways that you can help us recover the
lost money from the YouTube advertiser
boycott number one you can become a
member members get a daily Members Only
show called the bonus show that we do
members get commercial free audio and
video streams of the show just for you
and membership is has sort of been the
biggest funding source for the show for
a long time it used to slightly exceed
YouTube as a revenue source now it
drastically exceeds it because of the
crash you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership we have a
new coupon code for you ok it is 40 on
4th in honor of the 4th of July you will
get 40% off of your membership if you
use the coupon code for tea on 4th
that's the number 44 zero the word on Oh
N and fourth spelled for th 4 0 o n 4 th
number two you can make a contribution
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
ok even if you've only got $1 a month to
contribute that makes up for the lost
revenue from we asked to estimate 2 to 3
YouTube viewers okay so if you can go
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
just pledged $1 okay if just 2% of our
audience did that this problem is over
so be part of the 2% you can go to
patreon.com/scishow it takes a minute to
do that if you shop on amazon.com you
can go to david pakman.com slash amazon
and everything you buy will send us a
kickback that's something we've been
doing for a while if you have a YouTube
red subscription watch all of our videos
all the time because we get a fraction
of that YouTube read monthly fee and
lastly you can get your gear which
includes bumper stickers david pakman
show coffee or cobb Bethy we've tried
making cup feffy actually the david
pakman show coffee and it was it was
okay it was a little acidic well frothy
ode so it was frothy and acidic that's
exactly right I like where you're going
without that bumper stickers Cobb feffy
as well as t-shirts and hoodies at david
pakman.com slash gear this is extra bad
right now
because of the attacks on media by the
Trump administration disregard for media
freedoms we need to support diversity of
voices as much as possible if you can
contribute $1 a month
please do it patreon is a cumulative
process as of this morning as you can
see at patreon.com slash david pakman
show we had 14 hundred and eighty nine
patrons I would love to get to 2,000
patrons help us get to 2,000 patrons
even a dollar a month you could do a
hundred a month you could do a thousand
a month you could do 10,000 a month but
the minimum is just $1 a month and the
new coupon code for tea on 4th at david
pakman.com slash membership we need your
help
we really do if you have any other ideas
or contributions you want to make always
feel free to get in touch directly
through our website hopefully good news
on that coming soon